mr. stars you play Cogsworth and
Cogsworth is yes he's he's quite a
unique character in this film I
understand you were asked to improvise a
lot so could you talk about working with
Cogsworth and where Cogsworth various
personality came from I don't recall
being asked to improvise I'm an inch and
they'll take a yard diplomatically put I
would I would get ideas from lines and
jot things down and ask them at the end
of a scene take if I could go back and I
had some ideas about stuff and
occasionally it worked rather nicely if
you're after getting me to to remark on
the the moment that Robbie asks
Cogsworth how on earth can I convince
her that I'm sincere what do I say to
her and my improvised response was Oh
flowers chocolates promises you don't
intend to keep as Robbie is careful to
point out we draw from our real lives so
Richard you portrayed the for lack of a
better term villain of the piece people
use that word yes oh yes yes terrible
he's misunderstood yes so could you talk
about the and I think that that's
oftentimes one of their harder parts to
play because you want the villain to be
a three-dimensional character you need
to be us you don't necessarily want the
audience to like you but you don't want
them to misunderstand completely they
want there to be some semblance of
reality and truth to it to the character
so talk about working I don't know
I'm told that he's guest on this very
unusual
in the Disney canon in that he the
villain a villain who is not ugly a
villain who is not mean all the time and
he's not he's very charming the women in
town fall all over him a lot of people
find him now they do they find him very
attractive with attractive qualities but
my first experience of the character
came through Howard and through Allen
and through the music initially then I
got to see some of the renderings what a
lot of work had already been done
we saw images of what characters would
look like and so you had the opportunity
to envision your character in in his the
body that they might give him it they
continued to evolve but you had a notion
of what that was and you knew what he
was going to what his music was going to
sound like and what his words were going
to sound like and so you had a wonderful
place to start and as everyone has
indicated Howard had a way of
communicating these characters to you on
a level that he could play all of them
he did but but it was thrilling you fell
in love with your character immediately
and Gaston is a lot to get to fall in
love with I mean it really is I mean
come on
so
what could they mean so I got the
opportunity to sort of revel in that and
it doesn't really get any better than
that
so andreas it's I think any animator
will tell you that the hardest thing to
do or to animate is a human form
especially one that's you know you want
to be believable so in a way I think you
were given a really tough job and at the
same time you were also given the job of
you know doing this kind of there as he
said good-looking villain so there's
some extra work happening that yeah
extra work happening there so could you
talk about the challenges of I think EXO
actually guest on started out as an
entirely different design if I'm not
mistaken so can you talk about yeah a
little bit of a hard time getting a hold
of Gaston visually I mean I understood
the character from a story point of view
and Rich's readings but but to set his
look was really hard because I took a
look at what the story people had done
and they drew him as a cartoon character
you know sort of caricature with a big
jar I kept it hook and a mustache and I
thought I'm gonna have some fun with
this guy so I did my first scene which
was doing the opening song with that
model in mind big jaw big muscles and
all that and Jeffrey Katzenberg or then
boss said well he said the acting is
fine but he's not handsome enough I'm
going handsome he's the villain come on
you know so he said no no he has to be
handsome and I thought oh man does he
want like a soap opera star is the
villain how is that gonna work you know
so I got a little pouty and I did I did
I did some soap opera type drawings I've
got so much I hate it I say is this what
you want and but then Jeffrey called me
into his office about a couple of weeks
later I remember and he said look what
the story that we are trying to tell
here is don't judge the book by its
cover so that means when we meet the
beast he is sorry he is horrible looking
he's scary looking but we find out
throughout the story he has a heart of
gold so Gaston has to have the opposite
qualities we see him and he looks like a
handsome young man who should or might
marry Belle but we find out he's a male
show
this is completely full of himself and
becomes a murderer in the end there's a
lot so that has to be clear and I said
but if he's handsome that's going to
make it so much more difficult and
Jeffrey said well nobody said it was
going to be easy and that was the end of
the meeting so I understand that one of
the big debates going on a month that
you actually had a competition for was
all about chest hair oh yeah the chest
hair story there was that famous line
during the song and every last inch of
me is covered with hair so I handed that
scene to one of my animators and he
animated it nicely except when he opens
up his shirt the chest hair had a
peculiar design it was sort of combed
from the inside out
manicured and it looked slightly
unsettling to me I didn't know I didn't
like it and then the question was well
what is that chest you're going to look
like and everybody had a different
opinion it's going to be stubbles is it
going to be curly what is it going to be
so it became this contest and then we
settled for what you see in the final
film but it became a real issue